(rockets whooshing)
- [Narrator] In the wake of Hamas's
horrific surprise attacks
in Southern Israel,
the Israeli Army is preparing
for a full scale ground
assault of the Gaza Strip.
(rockets whooshing)
(explosions booming)
On Friday, the Israeli military
demanded the people of Gaza City
move to the southern part of the enclave,
because military operations
would take place.
(rockets whooshing)
- There is a term that is
often used in the military
called the center of gravity.
It's a term that denotes
where all the strength of
the enemy emanates from.
And obviously, in the case of Hamas,
the center of gravity is inside Gaza.
(explosion booms)
Israel's goals for this
operation are three.
Get the hostages back,
conduct a retribution for the attacks,
and to remove Hamas as
a force inside of Gaza,
so that it will never be
a threat to Israel again.
- [Narrator] Mark Kimmitt is a retired
US Army Brigadier General,
who served in Bosnia, Kosovo, and Iraq.
- It's very important to understand
how small the Gaza Strip is.
Its border is 25 miles along the shore,
and the border on land
runs for about 36 miles.
That's twice the size of Washington DC.
The challenge for the
Israeli defense forces
as they attack in is the terrain itself.
Not only is it small, but it's
heavily populated throughout.
There are very few open areas in Gaza,
and as a result, when
you attack into Gaza,
it is not a military operation
with long range tanks
firing against each other.
Every area of Gaza can be reached
by weapons firing in one
direction, or the other.
So from the moment the
Israelis cross into Gaza,
they're in somebody's gun sights.
Now, how would the Israelis attack?
Their goal will inevitably
be the city of Gaza.
Looking at a map, you would expect them
to come primarily through the center here,
to cut off the city of Gaza,
as well as use this little open area
between the populated south,
and the populated north.
At first glance, I would expect them
to come with their main attack into,
and as near as possible
to the city of Gaza,
to try to isolate it from
the rest of the Gaza Strip.
(horns blaring)
(person shouts in Arabic)
- [Narrator] General Kimmitt
believes a ground invasion
could complicate the
effort to save the hostages
Hamas terrorists took into Gaza.
- What is being asked for
in a full scale invasion,
urban conflict, uprooting
Hamas leadership,
and bringing back the hostages alive,
it's not something that's typically done
by a conventional army.
They're not trained to do that.
And if you take a look at
the terrain inside of Gaza,
particularly with the
extensive tunnel system,
and the fact that Hamas
has had years and years
to prepare defenses,
a ground invasion would actually
risk the lives of those hostages more than
increase the chances of them
being brought out alive.
- [Narrator] Zooming out,
General Kimmitt sees additional threats
coming from hostile forces
in Israel's neighboring
nations and territories.
- Going clockwise, you
obviously have Hezbollah,
which is a threat, but not a major threat.
They would probably attack directly south.
You've got militant groups in Syria.
The typical attack route is
through the Golan Heights,
or through Shebaa Farms.
Obviously, you have West Bank militants,
which could attack towards Tel Aviv,
but more than likely,
they will make their
focus towards Jerusalem.
And even in the Sinai
Peninsula and here in Egypt,
there remain a number of
threats in the Sinai itself.
Primarily, Al-Qaeda elements.
Any of these organizations
could be a threat to Israel.
They would be distracting attacks,
attempting to pull forces
away from the main battle
down here in Gaza.
But now that the Israeli
forces are mobilized,
I don't believe that they
would have the capability
to be any more than a distraction,
and not have any consequence
on the operations
against Gaza City.
- [Narrator] Zooming out still further,
General Kimmitt sees
additional regional threats
for the Israelis.
- I think it's important to
understand the far threat,
not just the near threat.
The popular mobilization forces in Iraq,
some of them have pledged
fealty to this fight.
And even down here in
Yemen, the Houthis in Yemen
believe it will be a multi-pronged war,
and we could very well
see Houthi involvement
on the side of Hamas in this fight.
I don't necessarily
believe that they will pose
as much of a military threat
as they would pose a diplomatic threat.
The normalization efforts
between Saudi Arabia and Israel
pretty much on the shelf.
The entente that was being,
or detente that was being developed
between Saudi Arabia and
Iran, probably on the shelf.
(people chanting)
Most important, the street,
the community of Muslims in the region.
The ummah, the street, is active again,
and almost universally condemning Israel
for the attacks that they
will conduct into Gaza.
(tense music)
(gun fires)
I think the history of Israel since 1948
has been a series of
conflicts that, in many ways,
resemble what we're seeing here today.
Perhaps not in scale, perhaps not in size,
but certainly in intent,
whether it was the attempt to destroy
the state of Israel in 1948,
the '67 attacks, the '73 attacks,
the repeated incursions into
Gaza by the Israeli Army.
Sadly, this is new in terms of its scale.
It's new in terms of the
tactics employed by Hamas,
but it is 75 years old in
terms of what Israel has faced
as a threat to their state since 1948.
(tense music continues)